[Music]
three two one action
hey guys welcome back Toph the record
ooh we talk about whatever we want but
today we're gonna be talking about that
JK party drama that's been request
requested by our patron mark Avendano
thank you for mark
hi mark thanks for being up a throne
yeah so if you guys haven't been patreon
yet and you want to ask your own
questions make sure to check out the
link in the description and check out
our patreon that's right get lots of
extra videos yeah 24 every month eight
and you get to ask us questions like
mark like this like mark yeah take your
party drama this was never addressed it
arrested addressed it addressed it it it
makes sense yeah we never really spoke
about it I mean Nikki commented and a
lot of people were wondering like what
is the state of just kidding party
what's going on especially with like are
you ever gonna come back and like you
know what started at all maybe we could
attach Anthony yeah cuz I'm sure the JK
news audience might know it might just
be a small overlap of JK party and JK
news I'm I don't matter barely maybe
like what am I saying
there might only be like 10,000 people I
thought I know and then there's like
nine hundred ninety thousand they're
like what do you so the so the small
summary is there was a video where Nikki
and TIFF had this game going on where
they're like they like to become it was
who extended pack yeah you could pick
your Alliance and they had this inside
joke where they they were always best
friends and they have a really good
chemistry and things like yeah yeah yeah
hustle it was a hustle and well like the
way that it all came out the order of
which the videos came out it came out in
in a way that was the their friendship
didn't develop and and and through the
progress of this in the natural progress
the way we were filming it that
friendship evolved yeah but those order
of the videos that came out because we
taped them like previously see them like
they were
of their friendship so people weren't
inside they weren't in the inside joke
right well it was a bit it wasn't
written like oh us against the world it
was no no that we did and people don't
know that we we film seven videos in one
day right and then we film every week
so and then they don't get released for
three months so by three months at seven
videos times four weeks times three
months that's like 80 videos before it
comes out yeah and so it was just one
big different order - in different order
and it's a different order but the the
you know but what ended up happening was
people didn't get what was going on and
they felt that they they ruined the game
or whatever and there was a lot of anger
behind that and then it trickled on to
their personal pages and everything else
and but it set off a whole lot of other
things and I think people don't really
know the whole story they just saw that
one incident and then they saw their
reaction to it and then they go oh so
you're gonna quit JK party now because
of negative comments but that's not what
happened yeah is that an assumption they
made that's an assumption that they made
a lot of people think that you know
Nikki's gonna quit JK party because of
negative comments from that one video
but there's really more to this story
and I think like this is the way they
got that info to is because uh like
there was that there was this comment
posted on the community page section of
our YouTube channel where Peter was like
addressing pretty much the anger from
the fans saying like because the fans
have been saying that they don't want to
see this Alliance the way it happened or
whatever it is that it just the fans
were just so angry and they felt ignored
so because of the fact that we have such
a crazy stockpile with the same exact
things that we didn't have time to
adjust yeah so then that's when because
B toy is like the manager of that whole
channel he runs it he came out and said
like hey guys it's my fault I shouldn't
have let this cute continue to go and
like you know he was pretty much trying
to nip it in the bud
but then that's what kind of sparked it
even more and and so there was even more
hate flooded and people
sort of coming over and being like you
may be choice where I take the fall for
your Chitti whatever and I was like I
don't even know what's happening this
was a game like eight five months ago
it's a [ __ ] tabletop game people so
[ __ ] pissed well I mean so the nature
of just kidding party and the I think
that it might be the same families but
the type of I think reaction that you
get from watching that that that channel
it's very different from this right from
here it's like discussion laughed or
whatever Jake your party's funny too but
I think the type of primal fandom that
you get is more like a sports channel
yeah where like you fight for the team
you're like [ __ ] that team this team
good so then there's team Nikki there's
team Joe and then people get really
height about the gameplay and we play
the game really seriously cuz I
definitely kind of encourage that
because we take the games super [ __ ]
serious so if at any time like you don't
play the way that they want you to play
you [ __ ] up the game and you [ __ ] up
their world so it brings a lot of
intense emotions into the the whole
whole whole atmosphere yeah and so from
that one post on the community page then
Nikki wrote a really long thing kind of
explained I was trying to provide
clarity to a lot of the things that the
fans are bringing up because a lot of
like there's some really good natured
fans that are like I just wanted to give
feedback you know so that the videos
could improve like we shouldn't be
punished for this and I totally agree
like a lot of the stuff I actually agree
with the fans because if a bit had been
released at the height of the joke and I
wasn't in on the joke the whole way I'd
be annoyed too I'd be frustrated too and
so I tried to address that in there and
how like you know I'm not in control of
how videos get released and how they're
stockpiled and if there's negative
feedback we don't have any time to
adjust because we were at that point
already finished filming all the videos
for the rest of the year so if you had a
note we couldn't like TIFF and I
couldn't go in there and go oh they
don't like this let's change it up a
little bit we couldn't do anything so
all we could do is sit back and catch
heat for all these videos that we did
months and months and months ago and
there's a reason why we do that too and
it's because me Joe Casey's yep I've
been working on our future films and our
pilots and stuff so there's a purpose
why we have to
so much so we can work on other projects
or else like a lot of youtubers you just
get stuck to that channel and because
there's no seasons you're constantly
tied to that thing so we're like we have
to kind of work ahead so we can do all
the other projects that we want but what
sucks is by working ahead one of the
downfalls is we can't make adjustments
on the fly because we've already pretty
shot at 80 videos for the rest of the
year yeah I mean I think all of this a
lot of our fans understand and and we
always get people angry for not playing
right or whatever but that's not the
main issue here I think the main issue
is when that there's just a small number
of idiots right that it really ruins
their their whole world to the point
where it starts getting into death
threats and real weird serious things
like that's the part I don't kill how
can you get so pissed watching people
play uno yeah you know I mean it's like
two people playing [ __ ] pessoa DOS or
some [ __ ] and then you're like [ __ ]
pissed but you know what the sports I
kind of understand cuz it's like you got
the city on your back
yeah you're like I bet 10 G's Chicago a
people on JK party
I'm like we're [ __ ] playing big 2 on
the table we're just friends don't have
a million dollar contract to improve my
batting average
there's no coaches there's none of that
oh no and yeah so for me personally at
the beginning of the year
JK party was always just like a fun side
thing for me you know it's I love you
guys like I think it's fun playing games
everybody was super competitive when I
was a guest on JK party so I was like oh
yeah oh yeah I could play this type of
game for the whole year and and so I was
kind of there to replace the competitive
energy that the OGIS had and since they
left but the rest like the rest of the
cast was kind of mellow and then TIFF
started stepping it up and actually like
we were super competitive like that's
how it started with us but anyway it was
supposed to be like dominate each other
well we were like well maybe we're
better together that's how the bit
started
because we were like so good at calling
each other out and being competitive
against each other it's better you guys
think oh come on
Geo oh but yeah so I was doing acting I
was running my own channel I was on Jo
JK news I was doing auditions I get
booked on stuff I was also running
around podcast and then later in the
year as things developed hey [ __ ]
started coming out our patreon started
coming out there's a lot more like I'm
just spread super thin so I always knew
that I had to drop something and so it
made sense that I would drop the thing
that was like the fun thing on the side
yeah so and because we had stopped
filming videos for the rest of the year
in June like the last time we filmed the
video was the end of June yeah I was
like okay well that's the perfect time
and I was already kind of on the fence
and then the this mafia video came out
where people exploded on me like a flood
of people came to my personal Instagram
and by the way I don't care if there's
tons of negative comments in the video
like I've dealt with negative comments
all my life I mean like I've been on
YouTube for 12 years there's lots of
negative comments videos have gone viral
and you get flooded in the video but
when it starts like flooding my personal
things like Instagram like I'm on a lot
of different platforms not just a party
game channel and and by the way I'm not
like that on any other platform so yeah
I just felt like like I'm going like I'm
going down and getting death threats for
that yeah over the way that we play
party games with our friends and our
spouses in a game where your spouse and
your friends are lying to you or you
have to lie to your spouse and friends
it's [ __ ] hype them emotionally
you're you never know who's bad and
who's good and it gets really hype but
it's just a game oh yeah and then once I
think what they don't understand is once
we yell cut it's literally like hey so
what do you guys want to eat later
it's not like this this this heat that I
mean this hate that we hold in our
hearts that were like [ __ ] you guys were
out of here you know
it's really like oh wow that was a
really good move man you like relying oh
my god you really like to mean the Pope
yeah and then we move on yeah yeah and
we're all adults thankfully okay so
y'all didn't sign up for that kind of
reaction right like you know I'm sure
they're thinking everyone's playing the
game and on top of that if you were
politicians you signed up for that yeah
if you were politicians you signed up
for the type of hate that they're gonna
send you and you're like ready for it
but you're doing DIY you're doing acting
you're doing all these other different
things that shouldn't bring that type of
attention especially on a game show but
for some odd reason this game show does
bring a lot of heightened emotions and
craziness which I love by the way but
that's my personality and it fits me so
I understand it yeah I get dude I got at
the end the other day that's like Joe
you should go [ __ ] and die
and then when me and me and we did it we
did a [ __ ] yeah but I'm used to it
I've been on this twelve years and I'd
like that because I'm like I accepted
your [ __ ] mind
I own you [ __ ] they're your [ __ ] yeah
but they don't know that see I came
Kardashian direct but yes I see yeah
that's not the attention you want then
that's totally fine by me I don't feel
like you guys are leaving in any way
where's we're friends so many other ways
you know it's just you got to pick and
choose how you want to put yourself out
there for sure yeah exactly because for
me personally I had been like on party
since for freaking ever so I had already
gotten used to on party they've just
majority not majority but like a loud
minority amount of people they just
don't like me on there so I'm like okay
well that can live there and that's cool
but then the recent stuff with the with
me and Nicki it just got so loud and so
toxic into all the other avenues like
Nicki was saying that like on my
personal dance I'm getting people a
little thing home horrible mother and
like how like how could you could you
suck out mafia or whatever your
mothering sucks because your [ __ ]
game play sucks
yeah like it's just so far out there so
ridiculous that to me it didn't like
obviously I'm human so it is gonna
I mean a certain level like a certain
degree but most of it though I'm just
saying that's so funny like it would
really affect you that much it has to
come bit like there were people because
for me honestly I could just block and
delete all day cuz it's really hilarious
to see that amount of energy going
towards me that's like that passionate
where I'm like wow dude you're clearly
projecting something but I could talk
someone's a good parent based off how
they play jackbox
so then like that's why I thought it was
the Baker so many times I thought that
was funny before creating new accounts
to literally talk [ __ ] to us or I'm like
well I can delete I could do this all
day but yeah like when when you come to
my space I have the power to control my
space right like my energy my world my
little world I'm gonna control it and so
that's it like I don't need to
continuously put up with this for that
it gets hard sometimes for people to
separate their understanding or their
expectation of like an online
personality from like an actual person
yeah right it's like thinking about like
a fleet if somebody's like ridiculously
good at like playing basketball you have
a high level respect for them and if you
meet them in person you think that you
respect them so much that should be like
a respectful person but let's say that
person is like from the hood that they
don't care about you at all and suddenly
they're like you're completely your
whole world is shattered because you
thought that this person was supposed to
be as perfect as their gameplay was but
like that's never the case especially
when it comes to a [ __ ] game show or
vice versa so like if they don't like
your gameplay then they don't like you
as a person and I'm like wow like the
way I play games is so much different
than Who I am a person because if in
games it's like yeah you are encouraged
to like lie and Bluff and steal and [ __ ]
like that stuff you don't get doing rape
in real life but then to like take that
and then project it onto all these other
platforms I was just like whoa that's
crazy how serious these games are being
taken yeah because you liked the least
[ __ ] person that I know thank you and
well yeah
asking for questions like that I don't
know because I'm surrounded by a lot of
[ __ ]
you're still hired I'm just kidding
but I think I think I think that win but
the way you play is you take [ __ ] really
serious like I do then I like the
competition I feel like we play we play
very serious but the difference is
you're such a good ass [ __ ] actor
people think you're serious right and
then I'm like sure yeah but but this
compliments on your acting then but yeah
to me I'm just like I don't get it
because I just as much as Nikki like go
intense but why does she get it but I
did read this thing about how few
females on social media they get more
[ __ ] than men do and and the reason for
that is because they're dealing with
both in cells and jealous women whereas
guys it's like well I mean it's it's
different so we don't get criticised for
the same things that women do a lot for
us it's like they might yeah that's
right a lot of [ __ ] about external
things like our skill sucks or this
sucks or whatever but we're not it gets
more personal for women right and then
and then and and and also like people
jump to conclusions about like a lot of
things maybe it happens for us but it
might be on our skill like oh you
probably can't lift that much because
there's something wrong I get heat for
it when I had role involvement there
like you're such a stupid [ __ ] for me
yeah it's it's a crazy world it's online
you guys have such a successful Empire
though right like you have like a
million fans without having like like
you said like 10,000 but it's unfair
like I did something wrong and then she
I get on my wait a minute why am I
getting my money back partner she gets
like 300 only why would you allow this
[ __ ] but it does make me feel better I'm
like oh [ __ ] I [ __ ] up but you're
eating my head maybe the people maybe
feel commenting I like Bob Barker boy
[ __ ] me up that might be into buzzy
Geopark [ __ ] me up to yourself yeah and
I think on top of that so me and Jess
did some investigating because we were
trying to see what was going on in 2014
or 15 but we saw it like an influx of
extreme negativity and we're like we
heard about that's when we heard about
the Russian BOTS and all that stuff and
did you know there's Chinese BOTS as
well now China pro-china BOTS yeah so so
well we're filtering throughout all of
this stuff right and then there's just
trolls in general that want to start
[ __ ] just to start [ __ ] and stir things
up and you're right with the more fans
and the more volume you have in
population people watching you the more
[ __ ] that's gonna come along with it
right so if now you have a million fans
and now you have 2 million fans that's
like maybe you had a hundred trolls but
now you have 200 trolls or whatever it
just gets bigger and bigger and bigger
and then so it's really important that I
think everyone look at the comments and
go wait some of this might not be a
human being some of it just might be
people talking [ __ ] like through box
right just to stir up issues some of it
just might be like a kid that thinks
it's so funny to make people angry which
I'm guilty of when I did that when I was
13 I did that all the [ __ ] time I
thought it was 30 yeah right and and so
a lot of this I think not just not just
in this circle but like um to have a
positive online experience we have to
approach all of this with like a little
bit of like this isn't that real I never
feel like everything I always like take
everything with a grain of salt like
it's never that real like you know big
stores like Macy's order if they have
secret shoppers right to kind of see
where people are and the managers and or
the the sales people they don't even
know they actually work for Macy's
and because I know stuff like that
exists I'm thinking it's probably very
normal to have secret commenters on
Facebook secret commenters on Instagram
so who knows what they're trying to do
they might be purposely leaving random
hate comments or good comments just to
test with analytics test with
interaction see how the whole forum
works so everything that that's outside
of my control in the world I just
automatically assume nothing is what it
seems
out of curiosity for like the haters
that are commenting and stuff like that
like what is the resolve that they're
looking for like what is the what's the
more like them the bigger moral to the
story venting and they approach it from
like a very righteous like I know more
than you and your [ __ ] on 12 I'm just
helping these videos better as a troll I
want to control them like if I like when
I used to like [ __ ] with people or
whatever like I want to get a reaction I
want to ruin one person's day or I want
to be right and have them listen to me
it's a control issue right like to get
an emotional response yeah
even if it's negative important you know
what I keep so I've been online for
[ __ ] ever now - and I would in the
beginning and get affected by these
negative comments because it was
something that I was obviously insecure
about and then once it was pointed out
and I'm like oh [ __ ] they see my
insecurity - and of course it just
becomes this bigger thing that I started
kind of like getting in my own head and
going like oh [ __ ] I got to start
filtering myself oh my gosh I gotta
start changing to the point where I
started feeling really trapped cuz I'm
like oh [ __ ] like nobody likes me and I
got to act in a way where people like me
and then I and then you just lose
yourself and then you're just like
you're just not happy with it anymore to
the point where you're just like why am
I even here and then trolls hitting on
you for trying to like better your souls
like that so that's what that's exactly
all the time I get so then uh then then
I started to think about like wait a
minute why is this affecting me so much
so then obviously I uncover that okay
it's cuz it's my own insecurity and then
you work on that thing but then when I
really thought about it I
how Joe was saying he did it right but
he did it because he was this sad kid
that didn't have enough hugs in his life
for something not you specifically but
well you might be right because I
thought it was so funny to cause
destruction he did attention so now I
read these comments and stuff and yes
they're [ __ ] ridiculous and and
you're just like wow like you're so
[ __ ] stupid that's like the initial
reaction but then when I sit back and I
think about it I'm like holy [ __ ] this
is [ __ ] sad yeah but this is so sad
that this person relies on us so heavily
that we play this game it doesn't go the
way they want like this is their
highlight and we [ __ ] up the highlight
of their entire month you know and and I
feel really bad and I'm like holy [ __ ]
this grown-up or this kid or whatever
and I'm just like [ __ ] like I block you
but I feel that's kind of the
realization I've had recently where I'm
like why is the whole projected
projection thing where I realize like I
have my own insecurities in my own inner
critic that really puts myself down and
so when I read the comments and they're
literally okay lighting it back it's
like [ __ ] it was crushed yeah yeah
exactly so then but now I'm starting to
realize that hold on like they don't
know me like I now I'm literally
physically out loud talking to myself
like just yesterday I was doing it and I
was just like cuz I read some comment
that I was like damn that's really
hurtful do it at all that accent golf
but then I was like no no but then I
caught myself that I was getting hurt
and I was like hold on first of all
let's close that why are we going there
um even though it's my personal self my
own answer that and then like talk to
myself like hold on girl they don't know
you they don't know this [ __ ] you've
been through your [ __ ] is strong you're
beautiful you've got this other thing
yeah I'm actually creating I'm working
on a manuscript a manuscript on how to
deal with online negativity oh you
really hit what the recipe is is a lot
of this negativity is just based off of
your own history and how you view what
they're saying about you and their own
cover this is a great opportunity
because most people will say I don't
want to be around this but when you look
at this as an opportunity and you go
wait why does this negative
comment effect me you'll start to
uncover a lot of your own insecurities
and in me I just sit there and I'll just
keep reading it over and over and I'm
like why does this bother me on why the
way I eat the burrito why does that
bother me so much why I eat it I eat it
the way I wanna eat it [ __ ] and
I'm like oh okay and then you figure out
mmm it's because I'm insecure about the
way I chew or whatever it is right and
then you start realizing a lot of other
things maybe it might be uncovering uh
his like a historical thing that
happened to you when you're a kid or
whatever and this is like a great
opportunity but it's scary and it hurts
that's why people want to avoid it but
once we figure that out I think you come
out stronger and you start going thank
you for all of that trolling cuz then I
was able to [ __ ] change myself that's
true but for me I still control my space
were like well when you're ready no like
I'm still right now I still decide to
keep my space clean just like my work
area I like to keep it clean like there
if there's like some like trash there
then it's just gonna accumulate some
more trash because then you know that
it's just gonna grow you know I'm like
let me just delete this for now and like
let me keep my happy space yeah I mean
it all depends on what you sign up for
please give me all the negativity
because I want it yeah
but the bottom take it from them and
give it to me I'll take it I think a lot
of what the JK party stuff at least I
think it got misconstrued by a lot of
people thinking that we quit because of
negative oh no yeah that was it wasn't
the case it was already like on the way
transitioning and I feel like you know
the begin of the Year David was here
then when David left Steve and I kind of
took over that spot and so I still feel
like I'm part of the group it doesn't
feel like I walked away or quit or
anything I just felt like oh that this
part doesn't make sense to spend a whole
Tuesday every week when I that's my
upload day and like all that stuff yeah
I mean yeah you're already on your
transition so it's not something it's
just it just so conveniently happened
that way yeah it's not because of
negative comments obviously it's
it's just the way that the outside sees
it but that's really not what happened
cuz it was addressed like I when I left
that comment and that was only because I
wanted people to know that they could
leave all the negative comments they
want we can't change anything yeah it's
like the videos are already done for the
rest of the year and so I think that
came across as like oh she's quitting
because the comments was nice to address
yeah like there's a lot of negative
comments but I can't do anything about
it on text a lot of things get missed so
I'm glad that we're making this harder
because I think this is really gonna
explain the whole real story behind
everything and I think you know for
those fans that were watching party
they're gonna miss y'all I think for
them I think they're they're most upset
like why the hell did you guys do this
[ __ ] now they're they're leaving the
channel because of you [ __ ] trolling
but then now they know that oh you guys
were already on your way out anyway yeah
and you can catch us on our other things
that all the other projects aren't
working on cuz cuz for me I'm really
glad to get my Tuesday back to focus
more on taking news and hey [ __ ]
[Music]